[Musique]
pour en parler nous sommes avec bruno
ben-meghar ban chefs de service
réanimation l'hôpital lariboisière à
paris bon soir bruno mais garbade merci
d'être avec nous rachid digoit
infirmiers président du collectif inter
blog dont soir à vous aussi de nuit me
les co présidents de la fédération des
syndicats de pharmaciens de
loire-atlantique les pharmaciens qui
auront peut-être un grand rôle à jouer
dans cette campagne de vaccination
bonsoir denis millet merci d'être avec
nous
les britanniques y ont donc dit oui à ce
vaccin le vaccin de pfizer et bio ntech
il sera disponible dès la semaine
prochaine au royaume uni je vous propose
avant de réagir d'écouter le tweet de
boris johnson
c'est fantastique que la mhra est
officiellement autorisé files heures
biotech contre le coc vite 19 le vaccin
commencera à être disponible dans tout
le royaume uni à partir de la semaine
prochaine
c'est la protection des vaccins qui nous
permettra enfin de compte de reprendre
nos vies et de relancer l'économie
évidemment les anglais qui se
réjouissent bruno m'égare ban
ils ont raison justement ces anglais de
se réjouir ou on va quand même un peu
trop vite selon vous en angleterre parce
que beaucoup le pensent ray ici en
france dont je prends ils ont tout à
fait raison effectivement la recherche
médicale a permis très rapidement de
mettre au point un vaccin efficace et
avec un niveau de sécurité suffisant
pour que les autorités sanitaires
autorise sa mise sur le marché
il faut savoir cette technologie tout à
fait révolutionnaire permet dominé au
plus proche l'infection naturelle avec
une stimulation de l'immunité non
seulement immoral mais également
cellulaire et probablement permettra une
bonne immunisation en tout cas dans les
meilleures conditions
donc évidemment il faut se réjouir car
malheureusement en l'absence de
vaccination
il faudra poursuivre les mesures
barrières et surtout au moment de rebond
remettre en place des confinement ce qui
est extrêmement néfaste pour la société
et la vie économique alors beaucoup de
réjouissance du côté de l'angleterre
mais beaucoup de doute encore on le sait
en france a notamment il ya beaucoup de
questions autour des vaccins en général
on va essayer d'y répondre avec vous
dans quelques instants
mais en tout cas les autorités
sanitaires britanniques elles se veulent
très rassurante je vous propose
justement d'écouter le docteur john
wayne c'est la patronne de ce fameux
régulateur médicale britannique que
citer boris johnson la recommandation de
la m h era a été atteinte à la suite
d'un examen extrêmement approfondie et
scientifiquement rigoureux de toutes les
preuves de la sécurité de l'efficacité
et de la qualité du vaccin fighter bio
ntech le gouvernement britannique a
maintenant accepté cet avis et a pris la
décision d'approuver l'usagé du vaccin
avec certaines conditions pour les
adultes âgés de 16 ans et plus alors
c'est vrai denis millet qu'on entend
souvent les français relevé que voilà
tout cela y aller très vite qu'on a créé
un vaccin en un temps record que les
études scientifiques ne sont pas encore
complètement complète les britanniques
sont moins méfiants que les français
c'est ça la leçon
alors peut-être que leurs
administrations vont plus vite que les
autres
le vaccin sera validée en france par le
même système
chez nous c'est l' agence du médicament
qui va faire ça je pense qu'on pourra
voir complètement confiance aventures
romancées validé avec des études pour
l'instant on ne dispose pas sur le
terrain mais une fois que ces études
auront été bien bien vérifié par par
l'ânesse aime ça pourrait sortir sur le
marché sans sans inconvénient moins de
vous donc on est en toute sérénité
alors c'est cocasse que vous nous dites
parce que c'est vrai que le ministre
britannique de la santé s'est fait un
peu taper sur les doigts par certains
aujourd'hui parce qu'il a assuré que
c'était le break site 1 qui avait permis
au royaume uni d'être le premier pays
occidental à autoriser un vaccin parce
qu'il n'avait pas le poids de
l'administration vous nommez garden
c'est quelque chose que vous comprenez
on est un petit peu lent d'un point de
vue administratif c'est vrai que les
autorisations sont souvent voilà
notamment de l'eau de la haute autorité
sont souvent longues à donner mais il
faut de la prudence tout de même nom oui
tout à fait vous avez raison
effectivement il faut bien examiner le
dossier dans tous ses détails
même si nous médecins n'avons pas accès
pour le moment donné il faut également
s'entourer des bonnes conditions pour
pouvoir vacciner la population car comme
vous le savez évidemment il y à des
conditions techniques assez exigeante
pour ce vaccin qui doit être conservé et
transporté à moins 70 degrés et donc il
faut bien sûr des réfrigérateurs le
permettant il faut donc tout organisé
pour que les choses se passent dans la
sérénité et donc effectivement
actuellement la circulation du virus
diminue on va pouvoir passer des fêtes
très tranquillement mais à la sortie et
donc au début de l'année 2000 21
il faudra rapidement commencé ses
vaccinations notamment par les personnes
à risque c'est-à-dire les personnes les
plus âgées dans les ehpad alors
effectivement le point presse nous en
dira plus demain sur cette stratégie
française
une chose est sûre on vient de le dire
vaccin disponible au royaume uni en
russie également à venir poutine demande
le début des vaccinations à grande
échelle la semaine prochaine rachid
digoit vous avez le sentiment qu'on on
commence à être finalement en retard
comme on l'a été pour les masques et les
tests on rappelle ce rapport la
commission de l'assemblée très dur pour
le gouvernement dans la gestion de la
crise qu vitesse que vous avez le
sentiment aujourd'hui qu'on semble
suivre le même chemin concernant les
vaccins le chemin je sais pas puisque il
ya beaucoup de prudence par rapport à ce
vaccin mais c'est sûr que voilà les
résultats de la commission d' enquête
et ben rhodes a vraiment tout ce que les
soignants ont dit depuis des mois toutes
les failles administratif toutes les
failles de la gouvernance et aujourd'hui
je crois que le plus gros pari s'avère
justement au gouvernement de de
convaincre tous toute la population
d'aller se faire vacciner parce qu'ils
ont quand même il ya eu une gestion de
crise qui était quand même assez
catastrophique
une première vague où il ya eu très peu
de choses de gérer la deuxième vague on
l'a pris de plein fouet il n'y a pas eu
non plus beaucoup de choses de en un
monde de gérer donc ça va être très
compliqué je pense pour eux de
convaincre aujourd'hui
alors pour être très clair on va on va
tenter d'y voir plus clair avec vous il
ya six vaccins pré commandé par l'union
européenne on va les regarder s'afficher
sur notre écran trois vaccins dits
modernes fabriqués à base d'ail rennes
message et trois autres dits classiques
le mec le vexin files r on voit ces
caractéristiques en bas à gauche il se
conserve
vous l'avez dit un docteur tout à
l'heure à moins 70 degrés impossible en
pharmacie comment du coup effectué sa
distribution à grande échelle que ce
soit en grande bretagne mais aussi en
france denis millet alors la partie qui
doit être conservé à moins de 110 degrés
c'est une parts et la majorité du temps
après ce qu'on a entendu dire c'est que
pour les derniers instants il pourra
rester quelques jours dans un frigo
normal il y aura plusieurs phases donc
la phase à moins de 110 degrés ça va
être réservé à des structures très
spécialisés parce que très peu de
personnes disposent du matériel
nécessaire par contre les quelques les
quelques derniers jours pour être
assurés effectivement par le relais
classique de nos grossistes qui vont
très vite et des pharmacies
éventuellement après pour arriver chez
les médecins et les infirmiers qui ont
requis le ferons quand quand ça sera
disponible en ville je pense que la
première structure sera faite notamment
pour les ehpad et les ehpad france 3
sera approvisionné directement par un
circuit n'était pas la peine de
multiplier les les étapes
est ce que le gouvernement vous a déjà
sollicité en tant que pharmacien dans
l'éventuel rôle dans le rôle tout court
que vous aurez à jouer dans cette
campagne de vaccination alors le
gouvernement a directement puisque enfin
la chaîne notamment puisqu'on a on a
émis des notre avis sur les
les premières recommandations de la has
a demandé même avant la sortie du
rapport
voilà on a été puis on est acteur en
contact que ce soit avec les ministères
ou avec l assurance maladie pour savoir
pour dire dans quelle mesure nous serons
impliqués soit pour l'acheminement mais
probablement aussi dès que ça passera
pourra plus grand nombre pour pour la
vaccination elle même alors qui pourra
se faire vacciner quand c'est la grande
question que tous les français se posent
jean castex a commencé à livrer de plus
en plus de détails ça doit être annoncé
demain quand je vous propose d'écouter
le premier ministre nous avons pré
commandé par le système européen de quoi
vacciner 100 millions de personnes
encore faudrait-il et là il faut tout
six mètres que le plus possible de
français acceptent de se faire vacciner
c'est un vrai sujet et faire accepter la
vaccination français finalement bruno
m'égare ban c'est ce qui va être le plus
dur vous le craignez vous aussi alors je
ne crains pas parce que je crois que de
les les gens sont raisonnables
donc effectivement ils vont peut-être un
peu attendre mais très rapidement ils
vont bien voir que ce vaccin a été très
bien su qu'il n'y a pas de risque à se
faire vacciner par contre il n'y a que
des avantages pour être protégés et pour
pouvoir reprendre une vie normale et
donc même si très probablement il y a
encore un peu de méfiance
rapidement je crois qu'elle va passer et
puis les personnes vont se faire
vacciner
ce d'autant plus que très probablement
dans un certain nombre de pays pour
pouvoir voyager pour pouvoir participer
à certaines activités
peut-être même sur certains lieux de
travail la vaccination sera exigé donc
en fait tout le monde n'aura d'intérêt
qu'à se faire vacciner
mais est ce qu'il n'aurait pas fallu
dans ces cas là la rendre tout de suite
obligatoire ça va pas compliquer encore
plus les choses et les retarder d'une
certaine manière de ne pas avoir rendu
obligatoire cette vaccination selon vous
toujours bruno me garbade non je crois
pas parce que le rendent obligatoire
d'emblée aurait immédiatement attiré la
méfiance
effectivement on se serait posé la
question pourquoi rendre obligatoire un
vaccin notamment effectivement pour les
personnes qui ne sont pas à risque
10 vie du helmand de faire une forme
grave à nouveau ça aurait été
extrêmement utiles si c'était pour
protéger chacun d'entre nous mais là en
fait on se fait vacciner dans l'idée
bien sûr de ralentir la circulation du
virus voire de l'empêcher totalement
pour protéger les autres et donc c'est
vrai que le rendre obligatoire d'emblée
on était un peu difficile je crois qu'il
faut plutôt convaincre faire de la
pédagogie les très probablement la
population varades et les très
rapidement même si bien sûr on
n'atteindra probablement pas 100 % de
personnes maxi des mais le fait de se
rapprocher de 60% permettra d'espérer un
ralentissement important de la
circulation du virus est une reprise de
la vie normale dès l'été prochain est
denis millet quand on voit la défiance
en cette défiance scepticisme vous
rejoignez bruno mais garbani il faut de
la pédagogie sa pasqua par le
gouvernement c'est le rôle du
gouvernement mais aussi vous les
médecins d'aller sur les plateaux de
télévision les médias
c'est de ça qu'il s'agit aujourd'hui
c'est l'urgence oui bonjour ça va être
de convaincre je suis tout à fait
d'accord avec le docteur ben gardane va
falloir convaincre que le vaccin il est
efficace il est sûr et il va falloir
aussi expliquer vraiment aux gens que
l'intérêt de se faire vacciner c'est pas
que pour soi mais c'est pour les autres
parce qu'on a des parents des pâtes
qu'on a envie d'aller les voir parce
qu'on a des enfants petits qui sont
peuvent être fragiles parce que on a de
la famille ou à des amis parce qu'on
veut participer retournez voir des
concerts retourner aussi des bars tout
retourné vivre et que c'est c'est la
massivité c'est à dire le nombre de gens
qui seront vaccinés qui permettra de re
libérer un petit peu de coureurs nous
relient murray tous il faut tout le
monde participe faut pas attendre que
soient les autres qu'ils le fassent au
tous participé à ça alors trois chiffres
intéressants vous montrer pour alimenter
ce débat ceux de la campagne de
vaccination 2018 2000
19 35 % des soignants dans les
établissements de santé étaient vaccinés
32% dans les ehpad dont seulement 27 %
de personnel soignant qui se font
vacciner au rachid digoit vous alors je
veux pas être un 10 créateurs vont me
répondait si vous voulez mais vous ou
vos collègues vous accepterez volontiers
ce vaccin contre le coronavirus quand il
sera autorisé en france puisque vous
faites partir des personnes prioritaires
les personnels soignants
oui bien sûr je pense que le personnel
soignant est pas contre après on est
tous un peu méfiant cette cuisine tout à
l'heure par rapport à la gestion de la
crise après les voilà il va il va
falloir attendre un petit peu je pense
pour convaincre tout le monde puisque
lisa une étude où il manque quand même
pas mal de données notamment sur les
effets secondaires donc savais que ça
pose pas mal de questions et savez je
suis moins optimiste que mais que mes
collègues puisque moi j'entendais plutôt
qu'ils avaient a priori 60% des français
qu'ils aient hésité à se faire vacciner
donc je pense que ça va être un vrai
défi aujourd'hui le seul vaccin
qu'est ce que vous pourriez répondre
nommé garba noms commencent la pédagogie
justement rachidi quoi qui nous dit ben
voilà on connaît pas tous sur les effets
secondaires alors j'allais dire les
effets secondaires principaux
apparaissent dans les six semaines après
la vaccination donc là on a un recul
suffisant pour se dire que ce vaccin et
des non seulement bien toléré mais n'a
pas de risque mais bien sûr il existe
possiblement un risque exceptionnel que
l'on ne verra que lorsque plusieurs
milliers voire millions de personnes
seront vaccinées mais un nouveau ce
risque exceptionnel et à mettre en
balance avec la gravité de lakovic 19
notamment pour une personne à risque est
bien le fait de faire une maladie grave
le fait de décider de lakovic n'a rien à
voir en termes de probabilité avec cette
complication exceptionnelle éventuelles
du virus à la baisse pour les personnes
qui n'ont pas de facteur de risque de
faire une forme grave de l'aco vide il
faut savoir de plus en plus nous
observons des séquelles au concours de
la fatigue
de l'essoufflement même des cas de
syndrome inflammatoire past qu'ovide
nécessite d'ailleurs la
réhospitalisation de ces personnes qui
ont connu une phase virale peu
symptomatiques et donc dans tous les cas
évidemment le risque de complications de
lakovic 19 est bien supérieur un risque
théorique de complications du vaccin
quand vous entendez que la haute
autorité de santé oms recommande la dès
le début de cette vaccination en
priorité aux ehpad est ce que c'est
vraiment la bonne stratégie adoptée
selon vous de nimier
je pense que c'est dans les époques qui
est calé les personnes de plus fragiles
parce qu'il ya là j'ai déjà souvent des
comorbidités et puis également il ya une
circulation très rapide dans les ehpad
on le voit à chaque fois qu'elle n'est
pas des touchés il ya toujours un peu
tout de suite un très grand nombre de
résidents et de personnels qui sont
touchés parce qu'elle proximité le
travail à proximité des lieux fait que
le virus se répand beaucoup donc c'est à
moi de vie logique qu'on commence à
prioriser par ces gens là merci en tout
cas à tous les trois aux buneaux bruno
m'égare ban rachidi gouaille denis
millet d'avoir accepté ce débat alors
que la campagne de vaccination est au
feu vert au royaume uni ce sera la
semaine prochaine pour la russie et
prochainement dans notre pays en france
merci à tous les trois